joining us now live from his office and
the West Wing vice president Mike Pence
mr. vice president welcome back to Fox
News Sunday morning Chris I want to
start with those growing protests across
the country against the stay at home
order as some of the protesters ignoring
social distancing what do you think
specifically of their protests and how
they're carrying them out well first let
me say from the moment President Trump
asked me to lead the White House
coronavirus task force two months ago he
made it clear that we had one objective
and that was to save lives and in the
intervening two months the American
people have stepped forward have
embraced the social distancing have done
the mitigation efforts and as we sit
here this morning we continue to see
encouraging results declining cases
declining hospitalizations because of
what the American people have done
because of the president's leadership
and what governors have done around the
country we are slowing the spread we're
hastening the day when we can put the
coronavirus in the past and reopen the
American economy beyond the focus on on
lives the president also made it clear
that we wanted to ensure that our
hospital workers incredible men and
women had the resources and equipment
that they needed we've sped hundreds of
millions of medical supplies to the
critical areas around the country and I
must tell you the fact that no American
who is needed a ventilator has been
denied a ventilator is a great testament
to our national response at every level
and on the subject of testing we're
continuing to scale and expand testing
and we'll do that because as the
president laid out those guidelines this
week no one wants to reopen America more
than president Donald Trump and what you
see I think among millions of Americans
who've been embracing those social
distancing measures and making the
sacrifices is they want their governors
to find a way to responsibly and safely
reopen their state economies and what
the president laid out last week is a
framework a phased framework to reopen
America to do that and we're gonna work
very closely with governor's to
implement that as soon as we can respond
to the president it but mr. vice
president in a number of these cases
these protesters who are not social
distancing are saying they don't want to
wait in many cases they're protesting
your own guidelines to stop the spread
on Friday the president tweeted this and
I want to put it off liberate Minnesota
liberate Michigan and liberate Virginia
and save your great Second Amendment it
is under siege Washington Governor
Inslee responded the president is
fomenting domestic rebellion and
spreading lives even while his own
administration says the virus is real
and deadly so what does the president
mean because you you've got guidelines
that are calling for social distancing
and staying at home even your new
guidelines to reopen the country are
very phased and gradual what does the
president mean when he says liberate
these states the American people know
that no one in America wants to reopen
this country more than President Donald
Trump and on Thursday the president
directed us to lay out guidelines for
when and how States could responsibly do
that and in the president's tweets and
public statements I can assure you he's
going to continue to encourage governors
to find ways to safely and responsibly
let America go back to work and and the
guidelines are opening up America again
give a roadmap for doing just that Chris
four states that have 14 days of
consecutive declining cases that have a
proper hospitalization capacity we
recommend that they can begin under
phase 1 to ease the social social
distancing measures that have been put
into effect allow some people to begin
to come back to work allow some
activities in the community to begin to
happen and when the president speaks
about reopening America it's it's all
about encouraging governor's as soon as
they determine is most proper and most
appropriate
to be able to do that and do that
quickly America works when America
device is working and the president
wants to see us put the coronavirus in
the past by these strong measures the
American people have embraced but we
want to get America working again just
as soon as we can understood mr. vice
president
I want to talk to you about your plan to
reopen the country because there are a
number of health experts that say that
we need triple the number of tests that
are now being conducted and much more
contact tracing in order to safely
reopen the government can you tell us
that how soon that you're gonna have
500,000 tests a day which is what
they're calling for we're doing about a
hundred and fifty thousand now how soon
are we going to have 500,000 tests a day
where don't you think that's necessary
well under the under the guidelines for
opening up America again we create in
phase one a specific criteria for
testing that we believe is appropriate
to be able to test people that have
symptoms for coronavirus and be able to
monitor people that are particularly
vulnerable to serious outcomes nursing
homes and in particular populations in
our cities that have shown some some
vulnerability that's we believe the
testing that we have today Chris across
the country once we activate all of the
labs that can do coronavirus testing is
sufficient for any state in America to
move into Phase one we're doing about a
hundred and fifty thousand tests a day
and you remember a month ago we had done
eighty thousand tests total now we've
cleared four million overall but in a
hundred and fifty thousand tests a day
we think we can double that number by
working with governor's to activate all
of the laboratories in their states
around the country that can do
coronavirus testing that would put us at
roughly three hundred thousand but what
we're gonna make clear to governor's
again tomorrow in our weekly conference
call and I want to make clear to the
American people is at president Trump's
direction we're going to continue to
fully partner with governor's around the
country and health
in increasing and scaling the amount of
testing and we have every confidence
that we can have a sufficient amount of
testing to be able to to reopen America
not just in phase one but continue in
the weeks and months ahead to expand
testing in in ways that will give the
American people the confidence and the
tools to be able to go back to work miss
mr. vice president I got limited time
with you so I'm gonna try to squeeze a
few more questions and the 350 billion
dollar program to provide loans to small
businesses has run out
and you still don't have a deal on
replenishing that with another 250
billion dollars how close are you to a
deal with the Democrats the Paycheck
protection program that the President
signed into law has been an incredible
success and and literally has made it
possible for small businesses around
America to keep people on the payroll
over a two-month period of time while we
weather the storm of the coronavirus but
as the president I were literally on a
phone call with Republicans and
Democrats last week we learned that the
fund had run out and we are urging
Democrats in the House and the Senate to
step forward and approve an expansion of
the paycheck protection bill we're
closed Chris it's a briefly married
curse are you to it sir
the negotiations are going on we're very
close but I think every American has
seen the success of the president's
program to provide payroll support and
and we're gonna work to expand that so
that no one working in a small business
in America would have to worry about
missing a paycheck during the trial and
and difficulty of the corona virus
epidemic several sources now say that
the corona virus originated in a lab in
Wuhan and that the Chinese government
covered it up for for some period of
time which allowed the virus to spread
now speaker Pelosi says while the
president imposed his travel ban in
January he did he minimize the threat
from the virus here she is sir instead
of calling it a hoax and instead of
calling it and minimizing and say was
magically disappeared we lost time the
delay and the denial of deaths and
that's just the way it is mr. vice
president I'm getting this question a
lot and again I've got to ask it for a
brief answer what specifically is this
administration going to do to hold China
accountable well I appreciate you
referencing the fact that that by the
end of January of this year President
Trump took the unprecedented step of
suspending all travel from China no
American president had ever done that
and there's no question all of our
health experts agree that that bought us
an invaluable amount of time it's
enabled us to save lives and make sure
health care workers have the resources
that they need to meet this moment but
but it is clear to us that not only was
there a failure by the World Health
Organization to communicate to America
and the world what was happening in
China but also the China was not as
forthcoming as they should have been
with America or the world about what was
happening are we gonna do residents made
it clear well the president's made it
clear he's not happy he we're going to
make proper inquiries into this at the
proper time but I have to tell you the
one mission that this president has
given the White House coronavirus task
force is to save lives to put this
coronavirus in the past we're gonna stay
focused on that mission it's one mission
and one team we're gonna work with
governors across the country in both
political parties and I just want the
American people and to be encouraged by
the fact that we are making progress we
really do see downward trends in cases
and in hospitalizations and we really
believe that because of what the
American people have done because of our
incredible health care workers that we
are together as a nation hastening the
day when we will put the coronavirus
in the past and and get America working
again vice president pence thank you
thanks for your time during a very busy
period
please come back sir thank you Chris